يتدفق عشرات الآلاف من الأشخاص
إلى المؤتمر العالمي للجوال ، حيث
يمكن أن تعني الإجراءات الأمنية المشددة طوابير طويلة وعمليات
التحقق المتعددة من الهوية ، لكن سُمح للبعض بالدخول
مباشرة
بمجرد وميض ابتسامة اختاروا الاشتراك
في برنامج التعرف على الوجه الذي
طورته شركة ميكسيا الكندية الناشئة
قبل مؤتمر مثل هذا بأسابيع قليلة ،
تقوم بالتسجيل وإرسال صورة ،
ثم يقوم الذكاء الاصطناعي
بتحليل مائة وثمان وخمسين
نقطة مثل بنية الجلد ذات البنية العظمية
لقزحية العين والمسافة بين
عينيك التي يمر بها الناس عبر
خطوطنا وهم
قال إن
التكنولوجيا جاهزة تقريبًا
للملاعب ومراكز التسوق في أوقات الذروة ، بل إن هناك
حديثًا عن جلب التعرف على الوجه
إلى لندن - وسرعان ما ستصل قريبًا
إلى  خط أمان المطار القريب منك في
النهاية ، أرى أنه في
غضون ثلاث سنوات وربما خمس سنوات ستصبح
تجربة المسافر السلسة حيث
لن  يجب أن أتوقف عند كل نقاط التفتيش هذه ،
لذلك كنت أقف هنا
أشاهد الناس يأتون عبر
الخطوط وأعتقد أن
الأشخاص الذين يستخدمون التعرف على الوجه
قد يكون محبطًا ، فأنا أرى بالفعل
المزيد من المشكلات مع الأشخاص الذين يستخدمون الشارات
الاضطرار إلى مسحها ضوئيًا مرارًا
وتكرارًا وهم الأشخاص الذين يبدون المزيد من
القياسات الحيوية العنقودية بما في ذلك
التعرف على الوجه أصبحوا الآن صناعة بمليارات الدولارات
لشركات مثل الاستشارات
العملاقة برايس ووترهاوس كوبرز ، هناك أموال طائلة يمكن جنيها ،
وهناك الكثير من المعلومات التي
يمكن مراقبتها  استنادًا إلى أنماط
أو سلوكيات الأشخاص الذين يمكن
تحديدهم - التعرف على الوجه ولكننا
نعلم أن الإمكانات ستكون
هائلة ، وقد تكون الإمكانات ضخمة ، لكن
الخصوصية لا تزال مصدر قلق كبير
يقول ميكسيا إنها ستدمر
صور الحضور  بعد المؤتمر ، ما
لم نفعله هو الحفاظ على صورة الوجه
للأشخاص الذين كانوا
يقارنون بقاعدة بيانات أشياء أخرى ولكن من
الناحية القانونية هناك  لا شيء يمنع
القياسات الحيوية التي تم الحصول عليها من خلال
برنامج التعرف على الوجه من إرسالها إلى
جهات إنفاذ القانون أو المعلنين الجائعين
Samuel Burke CNN Barcelona